>> Greg: WHOEVER CUT THAT,
YOU'RE GOING HOME EARLY.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE DELICIOUS
THAN THE TRUTH SERVED COLD.
HERE IS TED KOPPEL TELLING OUR
NATIONS HALL MONITOR BRIAN
STELTER WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN VERY,
VERY GOOD FOR BASEBALL.
HE HAS BEEN WONDERFUL THE
INDUSTRY.
RATINGS ARE UP, IT MEANS YOU
CAN'T DO WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP.
YOU WOULD BE LOST WITHOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> TED, YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
>> CNN'S RATINGS WOULD BE IN THE
TOILET WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE PLAYING FOR LAUGHS.
>> Greg: I HAVEN'T SEEN BRIAN
STELTER THAT DEFENSIVE SINCE
ANDERSON COOPER STOLE HIS
TOUPEE.
KOPPEL HIT THE ARTERY AND
STELTER COULDN'T STOP THE
BLEEDING OR THE LAUGHTER.
KOPPEL KNOWS THE MEDIA OPERATES
ON TWO LIES THEY WOULD RATHER
FORGET.
ONE THAT THEIR EFFUSIVE COVERAGE
OF TRUMP DIDN'T HELP NOMINATE
THE GUY.
OH, BUT YOU DID, YOU BLUBBERING
FAVORS.
CNN LEAD THAT CHART UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT HILLARY HAD IT
WON ALREADY.
FOCUS ONLY ON TRUMP KNOWING
THEIR PROFITABLE OBSESSION.
TWO, THAT SOMEHOW TRUMP HAD
THREATENED TO PRESS FREEDOM.
HARDLY.
HE IS BUYING THOSE SAME
EXECUTIVES THEIR FOURTH AND
FIFTH HOMES.
SINCE TRUMP, THE PRESS HAS BEEN
FEVERISH.
EVERY DAY IS THE APOCALYPSE AND
EVERY CRITIC A FEARLESS HERO.
TO CNN, ESPECIALLY TO, TRUMP IS
EBOLA AND THE KKK COMBINED.
IT'S WHY THE C IN CNN STANDS FOR
CARTOON.
NOT A BELIEVER THE POINT BUT WE
KNOW HOW EASY THE PRESS WAS
UNDER OBAMA EVENT HAS HE
ACTUALLY TARGETED JOURNALISTS.
LET'S WATCH THAT CLIP AGAIN.
>> CNN'S RATINGS WOULD BE IN THE
TOILET WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE PLAYING FOR LAUGHS.
>> Greg: I HOPE THAT SHOWS UP
ON RELIABLE SOURCES.
>> Dana: IT'S SO TRUE.
>> Greg: LET'S GO WITH YOU.
TED'S POINT.
I CALLED HIM TED BECAUSE WE KNOW
EACH OTHER WELL.
IT'S NOT JUST AN OBSESSION.
IT'S A PROFITABLE ONE.
>> Dana: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY BRIAN STELTER WOULDN'T JUST
SAY YOU BET YOUR LIFE.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE ENGAGED AND THEY WANT
TO WATCH AND THEY CAN'T GET
ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T WANT TO WATCH OTHER
SHOWS.
THEY ONLY WANT TO WATCH US.
WE ARE BRINGING YOU THE STORY.
WHY WOULDN'T HE SAY THAT?
>> Greg: THAT WAS AN
UNCOMFORTABLE MOMENT, JUAN.
>> Dana: I JUST SPILLED ON MY
WATER.
>> Juan: YOU JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS YOURSELF.
>> Dana: VERY EXCITED.
>> Juan: YOU SPEAK WITH YOUR
HANDS.
>> Greg: JAZZ HANDS.
>> Juan: IT COULD BE.
JAZZ HANDS.
AT LEAST SHE DIDN'T FLIP US THE
BIRD.
>> Dana: THINKING ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: I THINK STELTER WAS
MAKING THE CASE OF TRUMP ATTACKS
THE PRESS BECAUSE, AND ALSO
BECAUSE IT'S ANTI-TRUMP NEWS
THAT DRIVES THE MEDIA.
60 MINUTES, WITH THEIR STORMY
INTERVIEW, GOT RECORD RATINGS,
HIGHEST RATINGS IN TEN YEARS BUT
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
GETTING AWAY FROM THE IDEA WHICH
IS THAT LES MOONVES AS, IN HIS
HEYDAY WHEN HE WAS AT CBS, SAID
GUESS WHAT VERY DONALD TRUMP MAY
NOT BE GOOD FOR AMERICA.
BUT HE'S GREAT FOR CBS.
THAT MEANS GREAT FOR RATINGS AND
EARNINGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE WITH THIS GUY,
STELTER.
HE WANTS TO BE THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION AND HE IS SITTING
THERE TELLING TEN KOPPEL OH, THE
NEWS BUSINESS IS MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT, TED.
REALLY?
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT STORMY
DANIELS.
THAT WASN'T BRIAN'S INTERVIEW.
THAT WAS ANDERSON COOPER.
FOR BRIAN TO MAKE HIMSELF
IMPORTANT, HE'S BASICALLY SAYING
I AM A VICTIM.
I AM A VICTIM OF TRUMP.
IT'S A HATE MOVEMENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS, WHAT IT IS,
WHAT IS OUR PEOPLE TUNING IN TO
WATCH THE MAN THAT HAS ALLOWED
YOU AND A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE TO
KEEP THEIR JOBS.
>> Jesse: HEAR, HEAR.
THE GREAT EXAMPLE OF MEDIA BIAS.
IF THE TOP ON BONDSMAN AT CNN IS
LYING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BEING
GOOD FOR RATINGS, WHAT ELSE IS
HE LYING ABOUT?
THEY WON'T GIVE TRUMP CREDIT FOR
THE RATINGS BUMP AND THAT'S WHY
THEY DON'T GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR
THE ECONOMY, ISIS, NORTH KOREA.
CNN'S RATINGS HAVE RIDDEN HIGH
ON THE TRUMP BUMP BUT THERE IS
STILL -- THEY ARE STILL GETTING
BEAT BY THE CARTOON NETWORK AND
HOUSE FLIPPING SHOWS.
A LOT OF THAT HAS BEEN CAUSED BY
TRUMP BRANDING THEM AS FAKE NEWS
BUT THEY'VE ALSO HAD A LOT OF
SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS.
THEY HAVE HAD TO MAKE MASSIVE
RETRACTIONS.
THEY HAVE RIDICULOUS CHIRON'S.
YOU CAN SEE THE HATE DRIPPING
OFF THE FACES OF SOME OTHER
ANCHORS.
THEY HAVE HAD TO FIRE WHOLE
CLASSES OF PEOPLE AND I'VE HAD
DEMOCRATS MOVED ME AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT, I'M A DEMOCRAT.
CAN'T STAND TRUMP.
I HATE TRUMP BUT I DON'T WATCH
CNN CNN BECAUSE EVEN CNN IS TOO
CRAZY.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO SAY
THE DIFFERENCE WITH FOX NEWS IS
THAT IF HILLARY HAD WON, OR
RATINGS WOULD STILL BE GOOD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: MIGHT BE BETTER, IN